there's an effort underway to remove DHS
secretary Alejandra mayorcas who is the
figurehead of this open border crisis
and some Republicans want to impeach him
and the Very the very
principled
reasonable moderate Republicans are
saying that this is a bad idea they're
saying that mayorcas mayorcas might be
terrible you see but he has not
committed an impeachable offense and
therefore because I'm a very principled
conservative not going to become like
those Democrats you see I'm not going to
actually wield any political power or
threaten the liberal establishment no no
no I'm just going to lose with dignity
yes that's right follow me on the bill
Crystal podcast next week and it's just
all completely
ridiculous there is a very very good
legal argument for impeaching DHS
secretary mayus very good argument
there's an even better historical
argument for impeaching mayoras and
there is an ironclad political argument
the Heritage Foundation actually has a
good piece on this I encourage you to
read the whole thing mayorcas FS
ignorance he says quote it's very
difficult to make sense of it it's very
difficult so I don't try to make sense
of it I'm doing my work I'm doing my
work and making sure it doesn't distract
me from it doing your work you're
emphatically not doing your work your
work is to secure the Border you are not
only failing to do that you are
intentionally not doing that you're
shering your
responsibilities so what's the legal
background here to impeach someone they
need to have committed treason you know
or high crimes and misdemeanors other
high crimes and misdemeanor so does this
count well it it would seem to count you
know there's only been
one uh cabinet secretary who's ever been
impeached in American history this was
Secretary of War
William bellnap in
1876 and what was he impeached for among
the charges
included uh were that he quote
disregarded his duty as Secretary of War
so you're not supposed to impeach
someone for Mal Administration just for
being kind of
incompetent but historically speaking
now we're going back 150
years the one time this has happened the
one President we have is that a cabinet
secretary was impeached for actively
disregarding his duty in his cabinet
position furthermore the house Judiciary
Committee outlined about 50 years ago uh
when impeachment is proper and
impeachment according to them is proper
when an official exceeds the powers of
his office or behaves in a manner
grossly incompatible with the proper
functions and purpose of his office or
employs the power of his office for an
improper purpose so even according to
that the 1970s
surely the
and that was obviously a Democrat house
surely mayorcas qualifies he is abusing
his
power his his behavior is grossly
incompatible with the proper functions
of his office the function of his office
is to secure the Border that's that's
largely his job and he's not doing it
he's intentionally not doing it he is
abusing his power by releasing these
illegals into the interior of the
country he's certainly exceeding the
powers of his office and he's seeking to
imply the powers of his office for an
improper purpose flood the country with
foreigners checks every bucks and then
then you get to that's the legal and the
historical basis but then you get to the
political basis we now use not we the
Democrats now use impeachment in this
country as just a kind of a referendum
on a leaders that they don't
like they impeached Donald Trump twice
but the first time they impeached him in
2019 they impeached him for acting quote
in a manner contrary to his trust as
president and subversive of
constitutional government to the Great
Prejudice of the cause of Law and
Justice and to the Manifest injury of
the people of the United States now that
is so absurdly broad especially when
we're talking about impeaching a
president of the United States it's
ridiculous it was ridiculous then but if
that's the new president can anyone
could Chuck Schumer even argue could May
orcus himself argue that he has not done
that is that he's not acting in a manner
contrary to his trust as the Secretary
of Homeland Security and subversive to
constitutional government he's
intentionally breaking the law and
encouraging hundreds of thousands
millions of people to break the law as
well basic laws like who gets to come
into the
country impeach mayorcas there's no real
argument against this good legal case
stronger historical case airtight
political case and yet there are two
Republican congressmen who don't want to
do it Tom mlin and Ken
Buck Tom mclintoch says quote the only
way to stop the Border invasion is to
replace the Biden administration at the
bab swapping one leftist for another is
a fantasy solves nothing excuses Biden's
culpability and unconstitutionally
expands impeachment that someday will
bite Republicans so this is the
classic squish argument I look I'm I'm
sympathetic to Tom mcclint talk I don't
want to unfairly malign him but he's
just flat wrong here this is the this is
this the worst refrain of the squishes
and they say
well listen if we in any way push back
against Democrat Injustice today
then hypothetically in the future they
might do it to us even though they're
already doing it and they've been doing
it for years they if we fight back at
all they the Democrats in the future
might continue to do the very thing that
they are doing to us right now can you
imagine boy that would that's sure scary
isn't
it well uh it's scary that it's
happening now it's not a hypothetical
and I wish we would do anything about it
he says it's it unconstitutionally
expands impeachment I I I agree I wish
impeachment were narrower than it is but
it does it's not unconstitutional it's
not ahistorical it's not illegal it's
not no it's
just it satisfies all of those
criteria historical legal politically
wise you got to do it the other one's
Ken Buck he's
retiring and he's also come at against
the impeachment efforts unfortunate I
hope I hope we can flip mlin talk back
because there only three Republicans
that determine the House Majority it's
not like this is some 20 member majority
it's a three vote majority so you lose
two of them okay well now you lose one
more and it's over and the the Democrats
are are very good at unifying the
Republicans are very bad at unifying but
if if we if we can't unify to take a
vote that is largely symbolic that is
totally justified by history and
politics and law to stop the issue of
our time the defining political ISS
issue of our time that is mass migration
the complete blowing up of our borders
and and an
invasion from foreign countries if we
can't do that what's the GOP good for
what are we going to do we're going to
cut taxes a little bit more maybe in the
future or something okay what are we
going to what's the GOP going to do
build violins that we can fiddle well
the country Burns okay fine if you guys
if the Republican party can't unify on
hey maybe let's stop the mass Invasion
that Democrats are using to create a
permanent elector majority then just
wrap it up man wrap it up and let's get
a new political party okay President
Biden has just come out and uh explained
a conversation that he had uh this was
at the beginning of his presidency with
uh French president franois Mand who
died in 1996 you know right right right
after I was elected I went to what they
call a G7 meeting all the NATO leaders
it was in it was in the south of England
and I sat down and I said America's back
and mean from Germany I mean from France
looked at me and
said uh said you
know what why how long you back
for then and he said uh he said to me
hey Jack he said uh you want to pass
that cant I said I don't have enough
butter there pal and uh we were we were
going swimming we went swimming down
there by the plane banjo and we where am
I this is the sort of stuff that old
people do in the final months of their
lives I don't I'm not intending to pick
on Biden particularly or or to be all
that provocative just anyone who's ever
had a grandparent Decline and die knows
that this is the sort of stuff they do
they confuse not just dates not just you
know this past Tuesday with two Tuesdays
ago they confuse decades they confuse
people they confuse figures into Epoch
it's not as though uh meand in France
was the previous president you know was
meand and then it was Emanuel macron
who's the current president of
France the guy was President of France
in the 80s through the early to mid90s
and then he died a year after he left in
1995 he died in 199 96 and what does
Biden know it's just like your your
grandparents uh on their way out they
would talk about you know Aunt Sally who
died 20 years prior as though they were
just talking to her yesterday I'm not
saying it's the six sense I'm not saying
he's actually talking to dead people but
he certainly is confusing whole epochs
whole eras of politics and the crazy
thing is that man might get reelected
man what a great clip that was now hey
hold up hold up man ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles Show
podcast we'll see you next time